22 juin 1906 un feu se déclare à
montigny le bretonneux
les sapeurs-pompiers où on t'a
interviennent avec une pompe à bras
une reconstitution historique d'une
extinction d'un incendie en ce début de
xxème siècle nous avons donc procédé à
l'extinction d'une petite maisonnette
confectionner maison au moyen de
sapeurs-pompiers en costumes d'époque et
qui ont mis en oeuvre une pompe à bras
et nous avons sollicité comme à l'époque
le public pour créer la chaîne humaine
permettant l'alimentation en eau de la
pompe à bras 2500 à 3000 personnes sont
venues découvrir le centre de secours de
montigny le bretonneux lors des portes
ouvertes ce samedi 18 juin
différents moyens d'extinction des
incendies du dix neuvième siècle à nos
jours ont été présentées à travers des
démonstrations
objectif découvrir l'évolution des
techniques et des tenues des soldats du
feu des simulations suivi de près par
les plus jeunes c'est aussi un des
objectifs de la journée portes ouvertes
c'est de créer des vocations parmi ces
parmi ces enfants parmi les jeunes des
ateliers ont permis aux enfants de
s'essayer aux activités des pompiers
comme le secours aux animaux pris en
charge par cinq sapeurs pompiers du
groupe animalier à montigny le
bretonneux une mission occasionnels peu
connu du public dans le cadre de la
protection des personnes de
l'environnement et
des meubles l'animal a une place
particulière au sein de nos
nos communautés ce qui fait que on doit
lui porter assistance également le
secourisme animalier représente moins de
8% de l'activité avec plus de 6400
intervention en 2015 le centre de
secours de montigny le bretonneux se
classe au troisième rang en termes
d'activité opérationnelle